all right today i have for your
consideration maybe the new most
dishonest fox news graphic of all time
now i'm referring but there's a
backstory here a couple months ago um i
told you about a different graphic which
at the time i thought
might be the most dishonest fox news
graphic of all time and it was a graphic
just meant to make joe biden look bad
and it was about the american workforce
and the graphic that fox news put up
compared the trump workforce at its peak
to the biden workforce in october
and it showed that there were three
million fewer people
in the workforce under joe biden in
october
than under trump at the peak
now when you looked at the graphic you
could immediately see it was an
extraordinarily deceptive cherry picking
of data
um
and you could see that they were cherry
picking the dates
showing trump in december of 2019 but
then biden in october of 2021 with no
real rhyme or reason it ignores the
reality of the pandemic it includes the
reality that you can
deceive very easily with labor force
participation because with a growing
population at most times in history the
u.s has had more people working than
ever before and more people not working
than ever before everything about it was
extraordinarily deceptive but
now i have a new graphic that might
actually be even more dishonest and
deceptive
on the dan bongino fox show where
bongino might have just been a guest i
don't know if he was the host here they
put up a graphic called
top 10 most unhealthy u.s cities and the
whole point of this segment is to say
democrats
say they're going to fix problems but
they actually create problems look at
all of these democratic cities and how
unhealthy they are and you look at the
map and they say oh portland maine is
one of the most unhealthy cities in the
u.s and right away you might be thinking
wait what portland maine
why is portland an unhealthy city
seattle washington portland
uh portland oregon that is san francisco
honolulu wait isn't hawaii super healthy
why is hano so
it looked like a weird graphic and they
cite a source and the source is
wallethub so
maybe you think wallethub is reliable
maybe you don't it doesn't matter but
right away we should be asking is this
actually what the wallet hub article
says
and if you go to the story on wallet hub
which we are linking to
you see that their map
is actually the healthiest cities not
the least healthy cities
the healthiest cities
that are identified are the ones that on
the map
fox news says they're unhealthy san
francisco
seattle washington portland oregon san
diego california honolulu dc austin
irvine
portland so you immediately notice first
of all they list irving texas when it's
actually irvine california on the map
and these are the healthiest cities not
the least healthy
um
if you actually
look at the unhealthiest u.s cities
according to this
analysis
they are
brownsville texas
laredo texas
gulfport mississippi
shreveport louisiana
memphis tennessee
montgomery alabama
fort smith arkansas jackson mississippi
not exactly liberal cities if you look
at the most obese cities in america
which is a factor in health
mcallen texas is the most obese city in
the country memphis baton rouge little
rock shreveport birmingham jackson
mobile
lafayette it is truly pathetic
and this is where i came up with this
acronym caps cap stands for
critically analyzed primary sources so
when you're presented with a graphic
like this
and it says top 10 most unhealthy u.s
cities
you your first question should be
is this a primary source and of course
it's not the primary source here is
wallet hub so your first step should be
to go and look at wallet hub when you
look at wallet hub if you identify it as
the primary source then you would say
okay
now let me critically analyze this well
what did wallethub do wallethub looked
at the 180 most populated us cities they
looked at 44 indicators of health
and
these are what they are and then you can
actually say to yourself is this the
right analysis is the analysis done
correctly what's being excluded what's
being included but most importantly does
the data match what fox is giving us and
the answer is of course it doesn't
of course it doesn't it's the opposite
with the additional typo where they put
irving texas on the map
instead of irvine california an absolute
and total humiliation i would argue the
most humiliating
graph or chart
that i've ever seen on fox news if you
have a counterpoint if you have one you
think is more embarrassing or
humiliating uh let me know
i would love to hear it and uh by the
way a couple different dan bongino
stories one he's been kicked off of
youtube for spreading covet
disinformation and number two
they actually the the bongino people
reached out to me a couple weeks ago
inviting me on
to talk about
some kind of uh book band thing that i
hadn't heard about uh on a friday night
i wasn't available
should i appear on that show if they
invite me again
i'd be interested in hearing from you i
don't know that they will because i
turned them down
but if they invite me again should i
appear
with danbongino let me know info
davidpakman.com
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar that's why
you should check out our longtime
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman